- [Voiceover] This is Cruise.
He's a Malayan tapir,
and he is hungry.
(upbeat music)
Malayan tapirs are the largest
of the four species of tapir,
and are the only one native to Asia.
A close relative of the
horse and rhinoceros,
tapirs have poor eyesight,
but their sense of hearing
and smell are finely tuned.
If threatened or frightened,
they've been known to demonstrate
pretty quick bursts of speed.
They are also excellent swimmers,
and will seek refuge from
predators in deep water
while using their flexible
nose as a snorkel.
Although they are vegetarians,
they can also defend
themselves with a bite
from their razor-sharp teeth.
Their distinctive black and white coat
looks very smart,
and also serves as an
excellent camouflage.
Predators will often mistake
a tapir for a large rock
when they lie down to sleep.
Despite these adaptations,
tapirs are extremely threatened.
Deforestation and encroaching
human development,
like flooding from hydroelectric projects
are all threats to
their shrinking habitat.
This is the Malayan tapir.